welcome to hannity and we begin tonight
with a fox news alert we're going to
take you live to the ground on in the
ground in ukraine where military
activity is now ongoing at this very
hour earlier a new barrage of
indiscriminate russian bombing
completely leveling a local theater in
southern ukraine where hundreds of
innocent civilians were sheltering in
place by the way including many young
children in fact as you can see there on
your screen the word children was
painted on the ground in russian on
either side of the theater but russia
blew it up anyway and now an untold
number of innocent kids are dead tonight
now many major cities in southern
ukraine are being besieged there are
fears that keeve could be next and today
during his virtual address to congress
the ukrainian president zielinski played
this very powerful video showing the
true horrors of vladimir putin's bloody
invasion and war these images show a
normal happy country and the aftermath
of vladimir putin's murdering invasion
viewer warning what you're about to see
is extremely graphic for many of you
will be hard to watch but necessary you
decide
[Music]
so
[Music]
let there be no mistake vladimir putin
has blood on his hands he did all of
that ukraine will never be the same the
bloodshed is far from over and during
his remarks president zielinski he urged
americans to remember pearl harbor
september 11 2001 when our country was
under attack sadly his country is
experiencing their own horror now every
single day he also invoked martin luther
king jr and zielinski said his dream is
to protect ukrainian skies and now
president zielinski is begging joe biden
for help take a look
today
the ukrainian people
are defending not only ukraine
we are fighting for the values of europe
and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the american people are
helping
not just ukraine
but europe
and the world to keep the planet alive i
am addressing
the president biden
you are the leader
of the nation
of your obligation
i wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means
to be the leader
of peace
thank you
many americans tonight are asking this
question what should america's role be
when you see horror of mass graves and
dead children and women in the streets
what what is america's role in this
let me be clear what it shouldn't be a
no-fly zone over ukraine that's not
america's role that can't happen that
would likely put american fighters in a
direct fighting position and in war with
russia we cannot be the world's police
force uh u.s boots on the ground that
can't happen either it hasn't worked out
well in the past this would involve the
united states engaging then with russia
in a war and that could very likely
signal the real beginning of world war
iii with nuclear proliferation just a
button away but america we have a
conscience and a soul and we care about
innocent men women and children there
are many ways that we can help i go back
to ronald reagan he provided for example
the mujahideen in afghanistan the
stinger missiles well that helped
afghanistan defeat the former soviet
union in the 1980s reagan made that
happen reagan also provided weaponry to
the freedom fighters the contra rebels
in nicaragua to battle danielle nortega
and the sandinistas he was successful
there reagan never put a single american
boot on the ground these weapons help
these freedom fighters defeat bad actors
we should learn the lessons from reagan
give zelinski what he's asking for the
weapons that they need so they can
battle back against russia the ukrainian
people frankly they've shown incredible
courage and effectiveness so far against
russia they are showing their
willingness to do their own fighting
they're just asking for the tools of war
the late great charles krauthammer once
wrote enter the reagan doctrine which
relies on indigenous revolutionaries to
challenge for reasons that parallel but
need not coincide with ours the soviet
empire and its periphery now this
strategy effectively countered the
soviet communists like i said in places
like central america again without
putting an american boot on the ground
and not risking a single american life
this is similar to what president trump
did in 2017 with great success in iraq
this is after joe biden and barack obama
let this isis caliphate build out
without a large uh group presence donald
trump utterly destroyed the isis
caliphate using modern weaponry and
technology to do it pushing buttons in
tampa florida and with pinpoint
precision uh precision taking out one
target after another and two years later
president trump utilized a similar
strategy he took out iran's top
terrorist solomoni with a drone strike
in baghdad right there on the tarmac of
an airport again without putting a
single boot on the ground trump
projected peace through strength this is
peace through strength look i am a
registered conservative i like to say
when people ask me the media mob like so
how do you describe your political
philosophy well i'm a rigging
conservative um make america great again
conservative a save america conservative
an american first conservative now the
reagan doctrine worked the trump
doctrine worked we need to remember
these important lessons from both trump
and reagan and apply them to any future
conflict where american interests and
the cause of freedom are at stake and
now in ukraine without the possibility
of american air power or boots on the
ground it is critical that the u.s take
a moral stand in europe especially give
ukraine the ability to protect their own
skies and that would include sending
dozens of mig-29 fighters that were
offered from poland but unfortunately
our weak and frail and cognitively
struggling president joe biden
single-handedly nixed that plan and
today he refused to answer any questions
about the decision to block these
critical planes from being put to good
use by ukrainian pilots take a look
mr president what will it take for you
to send the polish migs that president
zielinski is asking for
they told me i'm not allowed to take
questions i get they get mad at me and
everything if i take a question they
tell me i'm not allowed i won't get my
ice cream tonight anyway we need to be
brutally honest here i don't trust biden
i don't trust kamala harris and i don't
trust nancy pelosi they are all
pathetically weak in terms of the
leadership the top three people there's
your chain of command and they are
enthusiastically cheering on zielinski
that's fine while denying him the planes
that poland was willing to give him
american politicians generally we
learned this through covid we've learned
it in past wars they are not to be
trusted i don't trust most of those
swamp creatures in washington
the last 60 years has taught the united
states a lot politicians they're all
gung-ho they start their wars they send
our national treasure our kids to go
fight these wars they don't fight to win
these wars they politicize them some
point thereafter and then say oops never
mind it's hurting my poll numbers and
they do that after how many american
kids fought bled and died how many come
home severely wounded uh
i mean debilitating injuries never again
we can never trust them again but we can
stand on our principles the leading one
being freedom now meanwhile europe
europe i have a message for you tonight
you've got to step up to the plate this
war is in your backyard not our backyard
it's time for you to pay your fair share
and your full dues to nato it's time for
you to get these important weapons and
supplies to ukraine and get them there
one way or another and stop asking joe
biden for permission but here's where
things get really strange and very
concerning back here at home the biden
administration is actually forging ahead
with their idiotic iranian nuclear deal
which is still according to reports
being brokered
this is unconscionable by russia and
china and according to the washington
free beacon this deal could include a
plan that would let russia cash in on a
10 billion dollar contract to build a
nuclear site in iran now if you think
the world can't get any nuttier there
you go it just got nuttier but it gets
worse axios tonight reporting that the
biden administration is also weighing a
deal to remove terrorists from iran's
islamic revolutionary guard that's their
top-tier terror
list so long as they promise to be good
little terrorists in the neighborhoods
in the middle east are you going to
trust them they're vile murdering
terrorists responsible even for the
deaths of american soldiers in iraq and
remember by the way this is a week after
iran nearly blew up our own consulate in
iraq with a ballistic missile not a peep
out of joe or kamala harris if these
reports are true joe biden is truly the
neville chamberlain of our time and of
course china they're watching all of
this they plot they plot their violent
what they call reunification of taiwan
really a takeover of taiwan recently
they vowed to impose the worst
consequences maybe even nuclear weapons
on any country that might help taiwan
militarily which by the way we already
do hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else